omicron is here all the government can
do now is buy time to slow down its
spread and allow science to catch up so
on tuesday we'll see the return of a
range of restrictions
firstly face masks it'll be compulsory
to wear one on public transport and in
shops but how much difference does this
make so i'm wearing a cloth mask like
most people do at the moment how much
protection does it give me and you in
compared to not wearing one
well a cloth mask predominantly is going
to protect people around you it's
designed to stop if you are infected
stop that infection um spreading to
others
and the protection it provides the
wearer is rather small
some studies have estimated maybe up up
to about 10 percent so i noticed you're
wearing a different type of mask there
so that that offer better protection
yeah so what i'm wearing is something
called an ffb2 mask these masks are
designed to protect the wearer as well
as those around you because what it's
doing is filtrating about 95 percent of
of air particles including the fine
mist which we now know can transmit
covey so the evidence is there but after
months of not having to wear one more
the public do as they're told
i think people overall will comply uh
with the new restrictions about um
mask wearing the problem is is that um
it's it can't be taken for granted and
we previously have had a lot of mixed
messaging about mask wearing about it
being individual responsibility and
psychologically that's potentially a
problem alongside face coverings pcr
tests for travellers are back anyone
arriving in the uk will have to
self-isolate until they get a negative
test results
this comes weeks after rules were
relaxed that allowed a lateral flow test
to be used instead so why the change
well a cheaper and easier lateral flow
test will still identify covid but not
the variant omicron a pcr test is able
to do this it can detect that one of the
three target genes called s-gene dropout
is missing
and now if someone tests positive for
omicron they and anyone they've been in
contact with will have to self-isolate
for 10 days even if they're fully jabbed
so what next in three weeks time the
government will review its restrictions
and already there are calls for them to
go further
we could see an extension on the mandate
of face masks people being told to work
from home or the introduction of vaccine
passports they're unlikely to stop
omicron in its tracks but could allow
more time for science and boosters so
more people are better protected
charlotte lomas sky news